so in light of all of that nevada's
economy still recovering from the
pandemic
businesses are looking for workers so
how can you stand out when you're trying
to find that job
all week long we've been sharing tips
and information to help you get back to
work
bianca holmen live this morning at csn
to show us some training programs that
can help get you
back into the workforce with a new
career bianca
hey good morning john so of course we've
shown you forklifts we've shown you the
manufacturing rooms we're now inside of
one of the healthcare rooms so uh belkis
rodriguez with csn tell us about the
room that we're in now
yeah so now you're in our dialysis
technician uh
lab and one of many of our health
healthcare professional workforce
training programs we've also got
community health worker
we've got ekg we've got cna and we're
actually launching medical assistant and
these are all accelerated
workforce development training programs
to connect you to the industry with
industry national industry certification
that you can take anywhere in the
country
all right well perfect and to tell us
more about the dialysis
program i'm joined by one of the
instructors mrs sue fold so tell us
about this program good morning
thank you for joining us so tell us
about just what students experience once
they enroll into your class
absolutely the program is three months
long
the first five weeks is spent in lecture
in lab in
a room like this and then the last seven
weeks
is spent in a clinical assignment
those clinical assignments occur with
davida as well as for seniors and also
lead to job opportunities
this program is leads to a national
certification
our certification that we offer is ccht
that stands for certified clinical
hemodialysis technician yeah and tell us
you know again once they finish this
program because they have that clinical
experience at the end they can start
working immediately and there's a
growing
you know dialysis cares is growing here
in the valley absolutely
because of our aging population as well
as folks with underlying diseases such
as diabetes
we have kidney kidney failure therefore
uh we don't kidneys don't work and these
patients need to be
uh treated three times a week usually uh
and so their routine is like a monday
wednesday friday or
tuesday thursday saturday yeah and this
is life-saving care for folks you know
if people don't get their dialysis
you know so people who are trained in
this are really trained by the best
you're one of the best at our training
we are the best
absolutely we're the only game in town
which is wonderful but it also means
that
we do have a wonderful uh
what a presence in the community as well
as
the uh salary the starting salaries for
these individuals is anywhere between 15
and 18 dollars an hour
good good so again all great information
again helping to save lives you also
will get
certified in cpr and there's other
trainings that you can get in
certification that you can get
while of course learning uh to know how
to do dialysis care because again this
is a growing field so all this
information available on our website
open enrollment class is always
happening so again if you're looking for
a career that
is pandemic proof health care we know is
it going to send it back to you guys in
the studio